Мені дуже цікаві ці всі програми якісь
розвитку інформатизації цифровізації які
чомусь вилазять боком зазвичай
волонтерам і тим хто надає допомогу
збройним силам України зараз якись
дурдом відбувається з інноваціями які
повністю блокує надання гуманітарної та
волонтерської допомоги Ми не маємо
можливості проводити нормальні закупівлі
на фронт жодна з цих програм не
допомогла вичислити те А хто з
комунізрив 36 млрд грн і які
Міністерство оборони переказало за
невідомо які стопорожні про контракти на
які немає жодних поставок Тому все-таки
треба було би включати мізки тим хто
пише цей законопроєкт чи проект бюджету
а не то що ви тут претензії пред'являєте
і передавати кошти там де вони можуть
бути найефективнішими для збройних сил
України бо інакше це все диверсія